la sentite ragazzi questa musica è
musica di tre è la tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti su shark simulators cerci
moneto ragazzi dovrebbe essere una cosa
un po trash sicuro però molto ecco
questo e gta 5 praticamente dei pesci va
bene
jacques comunque schiaccia simulator ed
è una figata
sei uno squalo che deve far fuori 50 più
di l'obiettivo del gioco e ci farà fuori
50 persone in generale eccomi buongiorno
è considerato non family friendly tutto
questo non lo so salve mi scusi lo
schivata razzi e salve
la polizia che mi spara occhio ma che
serve da tutta roma dove abbatte ma sono
qui io cosa vai avevano mangiato a aia a
posto buongiorno sono lo squalo che sta
facendo il terrorismo
eccoci 11 kg fatto finora ma basta dare
contro gli alberi verranno messe
l'intelligenza artificiale alla polizia
purtroppo 9 chissenefrega
buongiorno mi dispiace non volevo
ucciderla prova mi costringono è uscito
un nuovo film si chiama shark simulator
treni da andato a vedere e questo il
trailer bellissimo matt altro hanno
fatto tutta la città eco il figo non c'è
solo la spiaggia c'è la città c'è questi
hanno fatto una città per un gioco del
genere sciorba c'è anche il ponte è
l'obiettivo cile ricicletta persone poi
viene da in altro su tre stelle comunque
anche 1.200 dollari dove celio dove gli
osti dollari c'è un conto in banca del
mare oddio santissimo benedetto
buongiorno no e va bene la siete scemi
la polizia fa più danni di me ma corre
se pini le macchine ti dà dei soldi non
so con che criterio per ora sono sul
molo ci hanno fatto un modulo va bene
spero ci sia gente che poi non è che si
vedono uno squalo che striscia d'altro a
caso che vola in mezzo alla città non è
che scappano niente a quello scappa
quello sto scappando questo gliene frega
niente mi vuole morire
porca vacca buongiorno 49 c'è la swat
aiuto
50 ce l'ho fatta e sono morto rocio
fatta sono morto ce l'ho fatta quindi
quindi a risponde semplicemente rimani
sull'obiettivo che va dai ma c'è anche
la baia di santa monica
ma l'hanno fatto benissimo comunque
tutto questo fitto il primo obiettivo
così importante comunque vediamo se
riesco a comprare la grande spa di cosa
parliamo
cos'è sta grande spada scusatevi
previsto uno squalo che va in giro io sì
c'è un ponte enorme sul peer che dall
affare un pelo più piccolo sono le prove
che può in realtà la ruota panoramica e
sempre a sinistra però fan fair caja mi
sono schiantato nell'insegna aiuto e
ragazzi incastrato giorno c'è gente qui
big io credo che la spada si trovi qua
by the big four che senso dell'esame
quando qualcosa che puoi attivare tra
l'altro non so cosa ha poi gioca poi
entra nella giostra ma come veramente
aspetta human cannonball giappone wine
catch the human in che senso e tipo devo
fare una roba al volo giant del chapo
i'm here i stay human
eccolo l'ho preso l'ho preso e che fino
a e proprio a turni va bene ci hanno
fatto dei miei ragazzi se gioco e gta
ancora in aia porco demonio prima che ho
saltato da cani l'ho preso adesso è
saltato bene impegnandomi no che strano
se c'è il bowling il bowling penso sia
la cosa principale in tutto questo c'è
un morto anche li fa niente e camminate
come se niente fosse c'è il bowling
let's fly da noi ciò yourself and go lo
strike va bene ma times che cazzo ma dai
mi facevo fatto bene regalo calò questo
già che se già a me fare strike e non è
possibile
altro che wii sports comunque la rega è
impossibile fare strike e ve lo dico non
si può fare strike c'è pure la polizia
ma [ __ ] merkel di vederci
sott'acqua ma come ma come la pulizia
più vecchi del mondo uci qualcosa fuori
dei suoi sponsor la compro mix world di
susanne o se io posso posso usare le
armi ma veramente laser che non è come
fai usarla ma cosa vedo questo avuta
recita voli con quelli decisi a colpirli
con la spada ovunque è difficilissimo
e veramente un casino dare un colpo di
coda pazzesco
c'è una sorta di sweet home alabama come
soundtrack visto ciò che voglio comprare
la soundtrack è possibile comunque mi
hanno resettato le macchine in tutto
questo ho fatto la missione buono perché
la faccio solo perché voglio dei soldi
perché una volta che meritano voglio
comprare le armi nuove ci voglio quelli
un'arma non voglio la spada voi un'arma
vera o imparare colui che cacchio è
successo lì è saltata la stazione ma non
ho fatto niente io esaltata da sola io
non ho schiacciato ho fatto niente
fanno tutto 49 50 ancora quante macchine
ma come scelta dollari nel solo 100
dollari prova arpione consiglio e al
porto ok ciao ragazzi scusatemi cosa che
succede ma che si è imbarcato sono sotto
la città come possibile a sono riemerso
in città a posto niente ho risolto
rieccolo l'ho trovato sta sulla nave
attenzione ho trovato equipaggiare trova
un album
vediamo si chiama è diventata più la
madonna v
ma cosa avete cosa è diventato già scout
sto gioco henry cow my gal e quindi mi
posso attaccarmi alle rock madonna va
bene ok tutto tutto tra tutto bene tutto
ma donna che gioco realistico milan
addirittura laga cosa sta succedendo c'è
un calo di frame non milan che citiamo
il haga questo ok
i ragazzi sta diventando watson jeff
beck ti prego come facciamo dirigente da
dio
bravo sul jet black l'ho visto è un
jetpack questa roba è qualcosa che non
posso fare perché sono in missione va bè
mancano dieci secondi non cadere giù
perché non ne ho consegnato niente chi
se ne frega no ho trovato il mio arpione
paracadute vediamo come si fa a svetta e
vabbè vabbè si vabbè dai lo guardano un
commento niente perché dal cosa di cosa
stiamo parlando line ma che gioco ma a
che gioco sta giocando ragazzi l'unica
roba che voglio ancora fare che mi
interessa troppo per prendere un arma
però credo di avere abbastanza soldi
insomma da vedere che quella roba è
troppo importante fidatevi è questo ok
no la polizia
sarete le mie prime vittime ighalo
togliti allora machine gun corsa 15k io
andrei sullo shop can buy come si usa
così come uso come sparo come si spara
eccolo hai altra cosa
e va bene ma come si fa
mi hanno ucciso porco demonio non ho
capito bene non ho capito il tasto non
avevo capito il tasto aspetta fammi
capire a ok è questo che è perfetto ho
trovato è quello di call of duty
ovviamente che tasto volee di mettere
solo quando si gira riesco a picchiare
qualcuno ma si gira una volta ogni mai
ce ne sono state pacco le armi striscio
ragazzi questo era ash sharq simulator
vorrei trovare una spiegazione a tutti i
giochi simulator che sono usciti da dopo
go simulator che è stato in realtà
beh non è stato il primo perché c'era
anche surgeons penso che il primo sia
stato saggio un simulator di quelli
trash parlo dico di trash perché poi
vabbè ed è una cosa veramente
incredibile il fatto che comunque
continua a uscire anche nel 2020 giochi
tipo shark simulator siani spero che vi
sia piaciuto
io e mio fucile pacco vi diamo
l'appuntamento prossimo video discreta
dispiacere tasto mi piace e noi ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo video è
la ragazza
[Musica]